Nancy Pelosi and the group you heard her
the other day she wants to raise your
taxes they want to get rid of the tax
cut bill and raise your taxes somehow I
don't think that plays well but you
never know right
what's a raise your taxes these are
people that don't believe in borders
don't believe in fighting crime don't
believe in making a strong military they
don't believe in what the people in this
room believe that I can tell you so we
have to do a great job the president at
the susan b anthony dinner tonight
warning us about what is to come if
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats ever took
over Congress this November despite
Republican now leading and a generic
ballot poll against the Democrats you
have congressman Al Green he's exposing
the left's plan if they take a majority
you've heard it before but they're just
trying to be a little more quiet about
it but this is their plan believe it I'm
not sure that they'll be members we're
going to wait for someone else if that's
someone else doesn't matter who it is is
declining to do it we can all do it and
I think that there's a good likelihood
that there will be articles of
impeachment here with reaction Fox News
national security analyst Sebastian
Gorka former Secret Service Officer NRA
TV contributor Dan bungee no Dan we'll
start with you it's always been there
it's always been the case
Nancy will give in Pelosi will give in
to a left-wing base they want to raise
taxes they basically would like to stop
this president successful agenda but
more importantly they will go for
impeachment regardless there's no
evidence yes Sean do you understand it
they have nothing else right this is a
broken destructive disturbing shell of a
party that is drowning in identity
politics and rage at Donald Trump that
is manifesting itself through outrageous
calls for impeachment for fairy tale
collusion charges no one can provide any
evidence of Sean you can't win a
Democrat primary
in these radical far-left districts
congressional districts if you don't go
you know full psychopath and start
calling for the impeachment of Donald
Trump I mean they don't stand for
anything anymore the party's completely
broken well that's the point in dr. Gork
we have been discussing this
there is talk within the democratic race
just don't say it you know we believe it
but just keep it quiet let's not be
honest with the American people but they
are honest about yeah we're running on
the platform let's raise everybody's
taxes dramatically I don't know if
that's gonna work what else do they have
short literally we want to raise your
taxes what else could they do we want to
what bring back Isis we want to make
sure that the wall isn't built we want
the economy to tank
we don't want five million people to be
given cash bonuses because of the tax
reform they have nothing to run on but
Sean 2018 is even more important than
2016 because if they get the majority
they will begin impeachment and all of
the incredible things that the president
has done in just 15 months will be
stopped they will be obstructed for the
next seven years so 2016 was an act of
God yes absolutely but we need to make
sure that the flotilla comes up behind
this icebreaker who is Donald Trump and
make sure that make America great again
agenda is implemented for the next seven
years
think about this in January in February
there was a 17 point advantage
Democratic advantage generic ballot and
now it's a six point Republican
advantage I think it's the president's
success that has turned this all around
short people vote kitchen table issues
they vote on the fatness of their wallet
you know not the fatness of fake Russian
collusion charges which they've wasted
all this time on you know the Democrats
have learned nothing from the
impeachment of Bill Clinton and his
subsequent win in the Senate there in
that trial the American people do not
want the results of a fair and sound
election overturn by a bunch of
politicians up on Capitol Hill this is a
tactically ridiculous move that is going
to the blowback will be substantial if
the axe
do this yeah and dr. working what is
your take I look I've been saying and I
really have a lot of plans for this
audience coming up in the days weeks and
months ahead don't want to reveal my
plans a lot of copycats and uncreative
people in television radio so here's my
point this will be a defining historic
moment this midterm election it's the
most important midterm perhaps in
American history because this is going
to be about an election to destroy this
president that is all they have that and
raising taxes and gutting our military
that's it that's what they stand for but
they won't even be honest with the
American people about that agenda Obama
admitted Sean he wants to fundamentally
change America you don't fundamentally
change something you love this is our
window this is our opportunity there's a
very small window now to bring it all
back to bring back the Republic the
stakes could not be higher they want to
divide us they want to undermine us it
is only the midterms it's going to make
it possible to save the Republic it's
simply that massive a stake right now
Dan and you agree yeah I agree they've
learned nothing the Democrats from their
loss in Wisconsin Pennsylvania and
nearly in Minnesota as well they've
learned absolutely nothing
all right guys always appreciate both of
you